in the last module we took first steps
towards understanding the electrical
properties of individual neurons we
learned how electrical forces and
diffusion give rise to membrane
potentials and we learned how cells can
generate and propagate signals called
action potentials or spikes along the
membrane understanding the properties of
the neuronal membrane is essential but
understanding just these properties
isn't sufficient to give us insight into
collected behavior of the billions of
connected neurons in our brains luckily
for us we can approach neuroscience at
many different scales and levels of
analysis and we don't have to confront
the full complexity of everything all at
once that's what we'll be exploring
throughout the rest of this course as we
slowly go from our understanding of
single molecules such as ion channels to
the electrical behavior of neurons to
their collective behavior in small
circuits and finally on to how they
become organized in large functional
regions of the brain
let's start simple though since we've
examined one neuron a logical next
question is how did two neurons connect
with one another will first examine some
basic cellular anatomy of neurons so far
we haven't made too much of the fact
that the majority of neurons are
polarized cells that is they have one
portion of the cell for receiving inputs
and another portion for sending outputs
the parts of the cells that are
specialized for receiving inputs from
other cells are called dendrites the
word dendrite comes from the Greek word
dendron meaning tree and as you can see
the dendrites have a branching tree like
structure a signal received by dendrite
is passed to the cell body if there is
sufficient depolarization of the cell
body membrane to initiate an action
potential then an action potential is
sent down the axon
the axon then carries the propagating
action potential to another neuron so
what actually happens at the boundary
between two neurons between the axon of
one neuron and the dendrite of another
this interface is called a synapse there
are two general types of synapses
electrical synapses and chemical
synapses electrical synapses are less
common in our own nervous systems but
they're simpler to think about so let's
start with them electrical synapses are
basically pores between two cells that
allow ions to pass through they allow
the passage of the electrical signal
through to a neighboring cell without
much fuss it's not so different than
just combining two cells into one larger
cell there are lots of reasons that
nature might need synapses like this
from time to time they're fast and they
allow cells to couple together with a
high degree of synchronicity but most
neurons are connected together by a much
more complicated structure called a
chemical synapse in a chemical synapse
rather than simply passing along an
electrical signal from one cell to
another the action potential travels to
the end of the axon and causes a
chemical to be released into a very
small space between the two neurons
called the synaptic cleft
this chemical is taken up by the
downstream neuron on the other side of
the cleft this chemical signal can cause
the downstream neuron to depolarize its
membrane converting the chemical signal
back into an electrical one or can have
other effects on the cell
this chemical step is slower than
transmission across an electrical
synapse but it opens up an enormous lis
diverse repertoire of different and more
complex kinds of signaling and synaptic
function plays a critical role in
computations performed by neurons we'll
spend the rest of this unit exploring
the inner workings of chemical synapses
on our way to beginning to look at how
networks of interconnected neurons give
rise to behavior we'll also look at the
role of defective synaptic physiology in
neurological and psychiatric disorders
and we'll see how synapses can be
targeted by various psychoactive drugs
and poisons finally we'll wrap up by
looking at how synapses can change over
time in response to external stimuli
playing a foundational role in how we
learn and remember
[Music]
you